jorda savoir si 1848 c'est une d'actifs
dit quelque chose
cette histoire et notre histoire à tous
on est athée je suis à la fois temps qui
s est à la fois africaine ici on imagine
pas qu on a eu vraiment un membre de
famille esclaves ça nous met directement
en lien avec notre passé esclavage est
utile je n'ai agi que dans l'intérêt de
la france
trois balles j'ai envisagé un moment de
changer de nom que je le veuille que je
ne lui ai pas de toute façon ce nom
c'est une partie de moi qu'on pourra
vraiment aller de l'avant dans parler
aux élèves c'est notre mission et je
n'ai pas décidé de changer le monde mais
presque du 27 avril au 10 juin
les antennes première télévision radio
et web célèbre le mois des mémoires de
l'esclavagé
m